Aufregung bei den Nacktmullen:
Es ist Zeit zum Saubermachen.
Sie sind hier nicht in ihrer Heimat,
den ostafrikanischen Halbwüsten,
sondern in einem Berliner Labor.
Unter strengen Hygienebedingungen
sorgt Tierpflegerin Gabriela
Pflanz fürs Wohlbefinden.
Sie sind sehr, sehr agil, also sehr lebhaft.
Und die Haut ist so glatt.
Ja, Sie sehen ja, also man
kann sie kaum festhalten, ne.
Einen Bau aus Röhrensystemen errichten
Nacktmulle normalerweise unter der Erde.
Also, hier ist jetzt sozusagen
meistens das Schlafzimmer …
… dann sieht man ja, da, wo das Laufrad
ist, [ist] sozusagen der Fitnessraum
… dahinten das Kleine, die werden
meistens als Toilette benutzt.
Nacktmulle leben in Kolonien
– ungewöhnlich für ein Säugetier!
Wie bei Insekten gibt es Arbeiter, Soldaten
und eine Königin, die die Jungen bekommt.
Außerdem hat sich der Nacktmull
im Laufe der Evolution
an extreme Lebensbedingungen
anpassen müssen.
Das führte zu besonderen Eigenschaften,
für die sich die Wissenschaft
brennend interessiert.
Der Molekularbiologe Gary Lewin erforscht
den Nacktmull seit mehreren Jahren.
Wir wollen die molekularen
Veränderungen entdecken,
aufgrund derer sich das Genom
während der Evolution so entwickelt hat,
dass der Nacktmull diese
extremen Fähigkeiten erlangte.
So haben die Forscher Mechanismen
in den Zellen entschlüsselt,
die dazu führen, dass Nacktmulle
kaum Schmerz empfinden
– Erkenntnisse, die in Schmerztherapien
für den Menschen münden sollen.
Jetzt sind die Wissenschaftler
einer weiteren Besonderheit
im Genom des Nacktmulls auf der Spur.
Er sieht nicht so aus, aber er
bleibt quasi ewig jung
– und lebt für ein Nagetier
außergewöhnlich lang.
Weil sie 30 Jahre alt werden können,
ohne krank zu werden,
wollen wir herausfinden, was
an ihrem Stoffwechsel besonders ist
– denn das schützt sie vor Krankheiten wie
Diabetes, Herz- und Krebserkrankungen.
Fütterungszeit: Der Nacktmull
mag Pflanzen.
Außerdem trinkt er kein Wasser,
das gewinnt er aus der Nahrung
– auch eine Anpassung an die
Lebensbedingungen in trockenen Regionen.
In seinen unterirdischen Höhlen herrscht
zudem ein hoher Kohlendioxidgehalt.
Der Nacktmull hat gelernt, mit
wenig Sauerstoff auszukommen.
Das ist wirklich ein interessantes Phänomen,
weil es für den Menschen nützlich sein kann.
Zum Beispiel bei einem Schlaganfall,
wo das Hauptproblem ist, dass das
Gehirn dadurch geschädigt wird.
Und das liegt daran, dass es
zu wenig Sauerstoff bekommt.
Der Nacktmull ist ein
besonderes Forschungsobjekt.
Da er sich nur sparsam vermehrt, wollen die
Forscher seine molekularen Geheimnisse
auch auf anderem Weg entschlüsseln:
mit Nierenzellen des Nagers und modernen
Methoden der Stammzellforschung.
Wir versuchen aus den
Nierenzellen Stammzellen zu machen,
aus denen wiederum zum Beispiel
Hirn- oder Bauchspeicheldrüsenzellen
entstehen können.
Dann brauchen wir nicht mehr den
Nacktmull selbst oder sein Gewebe,
sondern können diese Zellen für
unsere Experimente nutzen.
Die Nager sollen sich hier wohlfühlen.
Für die Tierpflegerin ist das nicht nur ein
Job, sie hat auch selbst etwas davon.
Also, wenn ich irgendwie mal Ärger
habe oder ein bisschen im Stress bin …
wenn ich hierher komme und hab die Tiere
gemacht, bin ich die Ruhe wieder selber.
Die Nacktmulle bergen noch
einige Geheimnisse.
Zielstrebig wie die Tiere selbst,
arbeitet die Wissenschaft daran,
auch die zu entschlüsseln.